what's up
guys lunch money time bang bang
while wall street is trying to get rich
for us let's just trying to get our
lunch money right i have
no clue what polina is doing both with
her zipper
or this is like a sheep so
warm she's called it a bear she's called
it a sheep i don't know what she'll call
it next
that's fine but she's adding dress code
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto on their crypto exchange you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan
against your crypto collateral or you
can use my favorite product as both an
investor
and a user which is their interest
bearing account where you can earn up to
eight point six percent
apy in that interest bearing account go
to blockfy.com
to learn more man i got a face for radio
and a voice for audio can i just tell
the people let's go
so the other day he bought this new
black hoodie
and i asked them we went on a walk a
really long time you know why i like
this because it ain't got no logos
and we went on a really long walk and i
asked why he wasn't wearing his hoodie
and he said that he doesn't
want to sweat in the hoodie and he has
fancy and non-fancy sweatshirts
which to me all look like black
hoodies and i do not know the difference
hey listen you gotta have your
sweatshirts that you're willing to get
sweaty in you gotta have your
sweatshirts and nah this is too
exclusive i can't be getting sweaty in
it
this is a non-sweaty sweatshirt so
that's fine
they are all black that's okay you're
gonna see him wearing it every day but
he does not sweat in it
i do not sweat in this one you'll never
see me in my sweaty black
hoodie go ahead what's up okay uh
justice ruth bader ginsburg died
at age 87 on friday
um i like this lady yeah yeah well
i i feel like she really just kind of
did the things that she wanted to do in
life well basically
the the reason that oh man i lost my
screenshot
okay anyway basically she advocated for
equality
so thanks to her women can
get a credit card without their husband
um you know um women can like
be the sole care person for a military
vet
like things like that so i i she i feel
like she was just kind of a badass
she was yeah and she wasn't um
there's a there's a scene in mrs america
which is i think a show
uh where they reference
to ruth who was more of the quieter um
change maker and not one of like the
flashy feminists at the time
and that's kind of how she led her life
like she knew
which battles to fight and which to kind
of let go
got it all right r.i.p
yeah it is sad okay
she was 87. she was a little warrior
though she was ready to roll
um all right she had a very sweet
relationship with her husband based on
my research
because he was probably a nice guy he
was a nice guy okay
chime is now worth 14.5 billion dollars
surging past robin hood as the most
valuable u.s consumer fintech
company what well in the private market
well right
but okay it rate in series f funding it
raised 485 million dollars
they claim to be ipo ready within the
next 12 months
i have no clue why they're not going
public if they're close to being ipo
ready
485 million dollars in funding uh 14.5
billion dollar
uh evaluation oh no yeah valuation
in their series f they got a 14.5
billion dollar valuation raised 485
million dollars
all up here because i read the internet
uh but
what is very interesting to me is they
provide banking services on mobile
devices and so if you look at somebody
like a square
that i think last time i looked over 50
billion valuation
uh these folks are popping
they're growing fast but we're going to
see how how big this market is
um because they uh they essentially
built a challenger bank
um and so it'll be really interesting to
kind of see do they get a technology
multiple
or do they get a bank multiple when they
get into the public markets
they get a bank multiple that series f
might look a little expensive if they
get a technology multiple it may look a
little cheap
i saw chris speak at a tech conference a
few years ago
and it was so interesting because
everybody was like ah
challenger banks whatever but everybody
was all about he was surrounded i mean
everybody wanted to know about chime
so i mean there's always been interest
just even anecdotally okay
all right i'm telling you i know the new
technologies just ask me and i'll tell
you well tell me about tick tock how
uh our government is uh trying to play m
a
broker president donald trump's attempts
to force a quick sale of tick tock
produce the tentative deal
over the weekend that would see oracle
and walmart take a minority stake
in a new u.s company that will operate
tick tock so that's interesting
you want my real opinion i do this is
the dumbest thing in the world
well but why would he go through all
that trouble just to make it
it's not it's not a president trump
thing it's not an administration thing
what is it
it's the logic and the
uh inability of the media
and the tech community to call out this
nonsense
this whole thing of the government is
going to
start playing in
m a's right even what they're doing uh
around other national security issues
you're it's just a slippery slope and
this is what we're seeing
so when they went after wale right which
by the way
probably the concerns are real right so
it's it's not a question of is it real
or not
but the second they start doing that now
they can slap the national security
uh label on any company that they want
that is not a us-based company
constitutional
no it's not that's unconstitutional as
much as it's just a really slippery
slope and so
we have a government right now but the
climate is people are looking to the
government to solve problems
and so people are um petitioning
whether it is bailouts for the airlines
remember they gave them billions of
dollars and they didn't ask for
equity in the companies nor did they get
interest as a loan
it was just a grant so we just gave away
money and now the airlines are back
asking for more so
horrible investment from uh the
government now we've got them acting as
m a brokers and
they're not being compensated for doing
it two is
it's basically like an activist investor
all we ended up getting
is uh tick tock is still available it's
still owned by byte dance and now they
just switch cloud providers but this
stuff is stupid
and so if we're going to get serious and
we're really going to get tough on china
then ban it kick them out of the country
it's unclear speaking
they do it to us do it back speaking to
reporters trump said he approved the
deal
in concept i have given the deal my
blessing trump said if they get it done
that's great
if they don't that's okay too so what
does that mean just
like he's not living into the company i
have no clue my point is just okay
if we're going to have a showdown with
china
then you got to be serious and they
obviously have no problem do you think
china thinks we're soft
of course they're playing us remember
just again i will say this every day all
day long
china is doing things that nobody wants
to talk about
when was the last time that you read an
article in the mainstream press
about china taking certain demographics
of their country and literally putting
them on trains and putting them into
concentration
two-part series investigative on
buzzfeed okay
buzzfeed is not the mainstream media no
it's not yes it is no it's not
and so you tell me the last time that
you saw this stuff again
if this was happening in a european
country or elsewhere that didn't have
the economic importance that china has
to the u.s
this would be front page headlines all
day it's pretty crazy
what's going on so again we can play
this game all day or we can just go
after them if they're going to do it to
us
why don't we do it back they want to ban
american companies remember
facebook google amazon just go down the
line there's a bunch of companies that
are banned from in china
they're gonna do it to us do it back i
went to china one time and it was
wild to see like the firewall is crazy
to me
anyway all right what's going on
speaking of another company nicola
nicola founder trevor milton to
voluntarily
step down as executive chairman how
voluntary do we think the voluntarily
stepping down is
my guess is that it was probably pretty
voluntary
uh yeah but my guess is also that uh
you know there's gonna be some digging
through
the artifacts here uh so for those that
don't know nikola is an electric
truck company their whole idea is that
they've
figured out a better way to make an
electric vehicle
uh that could support the needs of large
trucks uh
they went public through a spac it took
off in price
everyone was yelling and screaming it
was amazing it's the you know next test
level
or whatever and then all of a sudden
there was lots of questions that popped
up some from short sellers
some from other people the sec started
to investigate
lots of pressure and now all of a sudden
the ceo is stepping down went to the
board and said i want to leave
or the founder i don't know if he was
actually i think he might have just been
the executive chairman
yeah his executive chair wasn't even the
ceo i don't think but he's stepping down
after all this pressure he said he
tweeted i intend to defend myself
against false allegations leveled
against me by
outside detractors i saw some of the
allegations
not great it's just they came after him
for making false
uh false um statements
like like promising things or whatever
you can't deliver there's a fine line
between uh
optimism for a founder you got to be a
little outside of
you know in terms of the uh the
rationale and the delusion
yeah and you definitely have to have a
level of delusion and all that kind of
stuff the problem is
uh if you do that in the private market
as an early stage company that's one
thing if you do it in the public markets
and you're making
uh claims to investors it's a little bit
tougher to
defend there and so we'll see what
happens i'm going to hold my judgment
because i don't know uh but what i will
say is it does not look good when
there's an sec investigation
uh you have multiple people kind of out
alleging things and then
the executive chairman steps down optics
aren't good but let's wait till we get
the facts
what else the coronavirus crisis has
magnified
singapore's food security concerns and
the city-state is looking to ramp up its
local food production tech entrepreneurs
want to help so
more and more local startups are
creating edible products from natural
ingredients and cell culture technology
some examples include lab grown milk
uh there's plant-based there's cultured
shrimp
and plant-based proteins
dope yeah such ventures could benefit
singapore as they can reduce the island
nation's import bill as well as its
carbon footprint off-camera king's doing
this
speak louder i can't
got a little mouse voice i don't
all right here's the deal everyone was
pursuing efficiency
now they're gonna have to pursue
resiliency and so of course food
production in every country
they're going to now put a very material
importance on
how do we grow our own food or produce
our own food so we're not relying on
other people
singaporean imports 90 percent of its
food due to land scarcity so that's
pretty crazy
so it might be a good idea if maybe we
get that down from 90 to like 50 percent
so that we can actually sustain
ourselves if something wrong
i think that's pretty cool although i
don't know like all the
lab-grown meat stuff like how that's
going to affect us in the long run
but we will see you guys well we're all
going to die anyways whatever
all right what's next okay i'm excited
about this
so anthony and his partner jason teamed
up
with an awesome artist named ferocious
ferocious felocious like ferocious but
ferocious
um and the best
the best truly the best and uh the first
piece
is a last supper style
dinner called the innovator's dinner and
it's with innovators instead of you know
like
profits the people i wrote about it
today religious icons go to my twitter
you can see i tweeted about it but the
people in it
are benjamin franklin john d rockefeller
amelia earhart walt disney steve jobs
elon musk beyonce jay-z dr dre
and malala and the entire thing is
created in a pop art style which is a
very specific type of arts
bright colors looks awesome uh and
they're all sitting there kind of
similar to the last supper
but this is called the innovator's
dinner because it is innovators across
multiple decades and there's a lot of
eating dinner together there's a lot of
tiny details in there that are really
cool
this iconic piece of art i believe
will serve as the quintessential example
of what is possible
in the digital art realm we've been
buying up a lot of digital art digital's
gonna be bigger than the nutritional art
market
bang bang you heard it here first ready
for my
joke don't walk yeah come on hurry up i
got things to do okay don't like
didn't do that make him laugh why
haven't aliens why is it funny that i
had a peek
oh my god why haven't aliens visited our
solar system yet
i don't know they checked the reviews
only one star
there's a lot more than one star in our
solar system
no the sun no jokes are only funny when
there's a hint of truth in them but the
sun
the sun's not the only star okay
but the the earth is a planet that's not
a star
no but it's close to this ah all right
guys
time for my joke no no no no let's ring
joe
let me do my joke this is completely
unplanned
but as you guys know
[Music]
nope i am one of the best ones by the
way buzzfeed's going to throw this
up here for me uh let's
see if buzzfeed can
come through okay we're just wasting
time tick tock tick tock
tick tick tick tick nope there's no good
jokes
all right here we go this is this is my
favorite site where my jokes are
why are you scrolling like you know uh
here you go
why did the researchers stop their
research on embryos
because the subject is still too
immature
that's it for lunch monday today zero
well wall street
is trying to get rich so that's just
trying to get our lunch money right
we'll see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money
as much as we did and don't forget lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends